elizabeth chambers has broken her
silence about estranged husband armie
hammer
and his alleged behavior on social media
that's left hollywood stunned
elizabeth took to instagram on monday
posting this
beach photo presumably from the cayman
islands where she and army have been
staying with their two children
she wrote in the caption quote for weeks
i've been trying to process everything
that has transpired
i am shocked heartbroken and devastated
in january direct messages surfaced that
were allegedly written by the 34 year
old actor
some of which included graphic sexual
fantasies
a firestorm was created around one
message in particular that referenced
cannibalism
it's not been confirmed these messages
came from army and he's called the
allegations
quote elizabeth continued in the
instagram post
heartbreak aside i am listening and will
continue to listen and educate myself on
these delicate matters i didn't realize
how much i didn't know i support any
victim of assault or abuse
and urge anyone who has experienced this
pain to seek the help
she or he needs to heal and she added
at this time i will not be commenting
further on this matter
my sole focus and attention will
continue to be on our children
on my work and on healing during this
incredibly difficult time
these new comments follow what e.t
learned amid the social media scandal in
january
a source told us elizabeth was in
complete shock by the allegations
and was feeling like her world had
turned upside down
following the allegations army confirmed
to e.t that he's stepping down from his
role
in an upcoming movie with jennifer lopez